Okay. I like to teach you about a new concept. These are
called HTML attributes. They look something like this. We still have our
opening tag name and, and a closing tag as before with this
slash but we have an, a new thing called an attribute. Attributes
have a name, in this case, I just called it ATTR. Equals,
and you've got quotes and the value is inside the quotes, and
attributes these days always equal a value. Didn't use to be the
case to be the case to be honest but everything we're going to
do is, is, equals a value. And tags can
actually have multiple attributes. An example of a tag
that uses an attribute is the anchor tag, which
is the a tag, and a full example looks something
like this. You've got the opening a, you've got
an attribute called href, you've got its value, in
which in this case is a URL, you've got
the contents, and then you've got the closing anchor tag.
So if you were to render this in HTML we'd
just see the word derp, but it would be a
link to reddit.com. Anchors are for making links. Let's play
around with this in our browser a little bit and
see it in action. Okay, so we've got our HTML
from before. I'm going to clean out some of these tags
here, so we have a little bit more room to
work. Let's make the, the words HTML here a link. So,
we're going to make an opening a tag. An href to www.w3c.org/html
and a closing a tag. When we render this, we
see that HTML has turned into a link and if I were to click this it would
open this page, w3c.org in a new
window. Pretty neat, huh? Okay, so quick quiz.
Take the phrase below or take the words my favorite from the phrase below and
make those words a link to udacity.com.